- [Narrator] This was Snap's
trajectory for most of 2021.
It's share value was steadily moving up
and the company was posting record revenue
and launching new initiatives.
- Off the grid and off the leash!
- [Narrator] By September, its
stock price had skyrocketed
over 700% from its low point in 2020.
But in October, 2021,
Snap's stock began to slip.
Since then, its share
value has fallen over 80%
and in August, Snap announced-
- That they will cut
20% of their workforce.
- Discontinue investments
in Snap Originals,
minis, games, and Pixy.
- [Narrator] So what went wrong?
It all started in April, 2021.
- Apple announced these
changes to its privacy policy
that said apps now have to ask users
if they wanna be tracked.
- [Narrator] According to
mobile app analytics provider,
Flurry, US users opt into tracking
only about 16% of the times
they encounter Apple's privacy prompt.
This makes it more
difficult for advertisers
to target their ads at the right audience
and get information about
how well their ads performed.
The impact of Apple's changes
showed up six months later
when Snap posted revenue
growth numbers that fell short
of what investors and
analysts were expecting.
Its stock price dropped over 20%
in after hours trading that day.
Other social media companies
like Facebook's parent, Meta,
also took a hit from
Apple's privacy changes.
But Snap is a smaller company
that brings in less revenue to begin with.
Investors got a glimmer
of hope in February
when Snap posted its first
ever quarterly profit
as a public company.
But it was short lived
because a few weeks later-
- The Russian invasion has begun.
- [Narrator] The first of a
myriad of compounding factors
that contributed to Snap's
continued decline in 2022.
Snap says it spent $5 million
helping its team members in Ukraine.
And as macroeconomic
conditions deteriorated,
advertisers pulled back spending.
- Snapchat, while it might be a place
where advertisers are
indeed putting their money
when they have money to spend,
it might be one of the
things that's gonna get cut
when they're trying to pull back.
Meta, which owns Facebook and Instagram,
which have slightly older user bases,
it's gonna provide better
returns generally for advertisers
because older people are gonna
have more disposable income.
- [Narrator] Snap was
also hit particularly hard
because the company relies primarily
on direct response advertising,
which are ads that are
intended to get users
to immediately click on or buy something.
Snap says this type of advertising
is easy to turn on and
off and to scale quickly
with high return on
investment for advertisers.
- [Derek] But that works
in the opposite way
when folks have to retrench their budgets,
and it's very easy to shrink down.
- [Narrator] Snap
doesn't report its ad mix
but has said that a significant
majority of its revenue
is direct response related.
This disruption in the digital ad market
plus Apple's privacy changes,
the broad effects of inflation,
and labor and supply chain issues,
all sent Snap over the edge.
- If it was one thing,
Snap might have been able to handle it.
But when you have all these
different things happening
at once, Snap's just getting
hit one thing after the other,
that's where the company
started to struggle.
- [Narrator] In the spring,
Snap continued adding staff
and launching new initiatives,
including a camera drone.
- [Announcer] This is Pixy,
a pocket-sized, friendly,
free-flying camera.
- [Narrator] And a content push
for its Originals scripted videos.
- [Simone] This is "Daring Simone Biles."
- [Narrator] Despite its new products,
Snap's share value continued to tumble,
and in late May Snap told investors
that its revenue growth numbers
were likely going to come in
lower than expected.
- Profit warnings are not
something that companies
just give out willy-nilly,
and so the fact that they did this
was quite a big deal actually.
- [Narrator] Following this announcement,
Snap slowed hiring and spending.
The company had previously
added staff at breakneck speed
during the pandemic,
growing its headcount by around
65% since the end of 2020.
Snap also brought on two executives
to specifically address the challenges
from Apple's privacy changes.
But analysts say they still expect Snap
to post a hefty net loss this quarter.
In August, Snap announced
it was shutting down future development
of its flying selfie drone, Pixy,
which it had launched less
than four months earlier.
- And then two weeks later they announced
that they were gonna lay
off 20% of their staff
and shut down many more projects
that weren't core to its business.
- [Narrator] Around that same time,
Netflix poached Snap's
Chief Business Officer
and Vice President of
Sales for the Americas
to kickstart its ad-supported
subscription plan.
Snap declined to comment.
At the Code Conference in September,
Snap CEO responded to questions
about a possible takeover saying-
- I believe that the best way
to realize our long-term potential
is by building an independent company.
And I think while the
stock price has gone up
and down over time,
we have slowly and steadily increased
the long-term value of our business.
- [Narrator] Looking ahead, Snap says
it expects the cost-cutting measures
to reduce the company's annual
costs by around $500 million.
Snap says it's also working
to diversify its ad business
by monetizing features like Spotlight,
which tries to appeal to content creators.
Snap says it's also working
to monetize My Places,
which offers users
personalized recommendations
of places to eat and visit.
The company also launched Snapchat Plus,
a subscription service that gives users
early and exclusive access
to features for 3.99 a month.
- Analysts, investors, myself,
we're all watching to see,
is the digital ad business recovering?
Are they diversifying their business?
If something happens again
to the digital ad market,
will it not affect them
as much in the future?
- [Narrator] Snap has been
through difficult times before.
The question again is
whether it can snap back.